alors j'ai très contents de l'accueillir
parce que je demande depuis deux ans
dans cette interview qui est ce que vous
êtes
est ce que vous êtes adamo et les gens
sont beaucoup adamo moi j'ai relancé
dave je ne sais pas si je pense que j'ai
dû dire à damas soir je pense que vous
étés d'amour et la prochaine fois je
vous êtes obispo et aux lisboètes bien
alors vous avez vendu 80 millions
d'albums en 35 ans et une moyenne
honorable c'est pas mal quand même hein
c'est pas mal c'est beaucoup non
franchement je croyais pas et au delà de
ces chiffres la même personne un brave
ah non mais c'est fou non mais c'est
vrai puis ça va mieux là pour vous au
niveau de l'image ces temps ci on
commence à dissiper un certain
malentendu
c'est vrai j'ai lu d'ailleurs beaucoup
de bons articles sur vous dans des
journaux comme comme libération comme
télérama et c'était pas il ya une
quinzaine d'années et même encore cinq
ans était passé c'était pas le plat non
c'est vrai que l'on m'avait laissé dans
le tiroir des chanteurs des années 60
fleur bleue moi je lis ma je ne me
déplaît pas du tout mes dix ans c'était
une facette de ma personnalité on
occulte et l'autre oui j'écris des
chansons plus concernés comment le culte
et que tu es du chevreuil d'amour donc
ce nouvel album s'appelle par les temps
qui courent
seize nouveaux titres écrits par vous
paroles et musique vous savez comment on
fait d'amour attention
et toi ça a déclaré la gueule bien le
single s'appelle le futur n'existe pas
le puissant frein parle
en oman
adamo le futur n'existe pas extrait du
cd par les temps qui courent à une autre
chanson ya quinze autres mandats il a
une qui a retenu mon attention c'est le
monde a mal que cherchez vous avez
écrite lorsque j'ai visité les camps de
réfugiés à la frontière du kosovo dont
tant d'absurdité je pouvais pas
m'empêcher d'écrire cette chanson oui
vous étiez en albanie à cou cassé sa vie
en tant que qu'ambassadeur de l'unicef
mais alors aujourd'hui qu'on voyait
l'expansionnisme albanais en macédoine
par exemple et cette volonté de faire la
grande albanie
est ce que finalement nous avons envie
de faire une autre chanson mais vous
savez ce n'est pas systématique il faut
que je m'imprègne du problème et puis il
ya des choses qui m'interpellent et
d'autres moins quand vous avez fait la
chanson qui s'appelait qui s'appelle
inch'allah sur jérusalem vous avez
corriger plus défini par corriger deux
strophes parce que vous aviez oublié de
parler de la souffrance de l'autre camp
si je n'ai pas peur avec cette chanson
qui se passe la même chose que vous
parler que d'un conte est ce que
finalement votre boulot mais là je parle
de peuple rejetée pour chasser donc il
n'ya pas de nation était précis alors la
sortie de cet album correspond au début
de votre tournée qui a commencé le 27
février à l'olympia ben southall fétiche
vous êtes le premier olympia en 63 je
vous regarde parce qu'avec vous ici vous
pouvez vous souvenir de ça
vous êtes non 51 vous ré entrée de m
j'avais une lapine plein pour leur
mariage est alors 63 donc vous faites
l'olympiade et cliff richard et les
shadows tourner la page quand même rêver
c'est shadows absolument bien si
l'entente première partie des beatles
l'air bien et puis après bon bah voilà
la tournée va continuer elle commence en
france belgique suisse québec et cd1
québec
ouais vous y allez quand dans
l'entretien je voulais qu'on revient
tous les deux mois tous les deux mois il
lui vient jeter les gants bien nous à
ces variables ça dépend quand je
travaille quand ils travaillent
josé maria riesch alors c'est aussi cet
été à des remous au score à un roman
vous avez écrit il sort chez albin
michel qui s'appelle et paisible coup le
la haine alors on s'imagine qu'il s'agit
de n est en fait pas du tout la haine
c'est une rivière c'est la rivière qui
traverse je mate pour j'ai vécu la
première partie de ma vie et je
n'invente rien je m'arrête au confluent
de la haine et de la trouille
c'est comme ça
on est reparti sa carrière un statut des
relances et des goûts bien en fait c'est
pas du tout n'est à jemappes mais vous
êtes né en sicile en 1943 cosim aux gets
l'aîné d'une famille de sept enfants
votre père était maçon il s'appelait
antonio c'est une émission très papa
maman semaine j'ai décidé et votre mère
s'appelait comme chet absolument à la
rue 1
elle s'occupait de la famille non et
vous dites que votre timidité votre
mélancolie ça vient d'al salam conchita
je pense lui même même peut-être la
façon de chanter chanter souvent des
cantilène sicilienne on vous en cousant
en brodant bien formés je connais bien
alors après la guerre que votre père a
passé dans l'aviation
votre père revient en sicile évidemment
c'était chômage et désolation il y avait
un comme ça une rumeur ans qui disait
dans n'auriez du travail dans le temps
et aussi en amérique du sud
je me dis souvent que serait devenue si
mon père comme mon oncle et ma tante
avait choisi l'amérique du sud
oui l'argentine et alors cette espèce de
phrases d'espoir comme ça circuler les
hommes parler de soizy dans le nord en
amérique du sud il ya du travail et
votre père paraît que sa valise en
carton
on peut réécrire sa copine et donc
quelques mois plus tard il revient vous
cherchez il a trouvé une place dans une
mine de charbon en belgique et en 47
vous prenez le train pour la première
fois vous avez quatre ans et vous partez
en belgique voilà travailleurs immigrés
vous avez d'abord à ghlin dans une cité
ouvrière c'est d'anciens baraquements de
prisonnier de guerre
c'était dur quand même des petites
baraque au toit pour en fait pour moi
tant que j'avais la main de mon père
d'un côté celle de ma mère de loin
j'étais bien j'étais au soleil mais pour
eux qui étaient très jeunes le
déracinement a dû être dur
vous écoutez comme la radio italienne
non swiss et baraquements la vie et la
vie est dure mais quand même
effectivement eu des bons moments entend
donc envoyé aux parents le dimanche qui
dansent en lacets et ça vous gagne un
peu votre vie oui je leur ai même didier
une chanson un hommage sans doute un peu
tardif comme c'est toujours le cas quand
je vois vos parents oui s'appelle les
heures bleues et pour pour les remercie
justement c'est bon alors drame votre
père un accident du travail valide à 60%
il peut plus travailler au fond dans la
mine et là que j'habite à jemappes
justement voilà est alors en 1950 et une
première maladie faisait pas de chance
et de la santé - oui enfin je m'en suis
sorti jusqu'à présent mais c'est vrai un
oui parce qu'après en 84 et le triple
pontage coronarien
oui là c'est la magie tous mes excuses
moi ça me fait rire l'accumulation c'est
comme le cinéma comique à l'accumulation
de mahler avant c'est drôle
ouais bah oui c'est de ma faute
méningite doublée d'une vaste audit
moelle épinière bloquer non mais
attendez
non mais bon aujourd'hui on en rit mais
ouais que j'ai pas fait pour être connu
et ça vous permet quand même de
rencontrer sur marie gabrielle qui vous
n'aviez pas porter que surtout appris à
lire à écrire oui à l'hôpital de louvain
mais non voilà et puis des séquelles un
peu moins utiles que lire et écrire
surdité de l'oreille droite toujours
sous l'oreille droite
oui à j'entends 1 40% disent on met les
pieds à cette paralysie d'un côté qui
lui donne ce côté non mais
mais c'est vous vous avez le visage un
peu paralysés à droite aussi non je ne
sais pas disons que c'est vrai que comme
j'entends moins bien droite je parle
vers l'oreille donc impossible que j'aie
la bouche un peu trash et maintenant
c'est toujours sa moitié du visage qui
sourit il arrive à chanter en stéréo
voilà bien vous allez à l'école où les
missionnaires blé jouer au foot
et puis là on nous offre une guitare et
comme souvent chez les jeunes enfants
quand on leur offre un instrument de
musique ici cole et votre père pour vous
payer des leçons de solfège économiste
très durement sur son salaire à 8 ans
vous traîner sur les marchés pour
acheter des 78 tours et vous de votre
premier prix de la chanson vous gagnez 2
kg de chocolat s'allume en chantant une
chanson de luis mariano c'était quoi
l'amour est un bouquet de violettes sait
comment à n'est pas connue serment m
bouquet de violettes ce soir que juncker
vous faites bien marianne et audi n'a
pas pesé bien
commencé comme ça sur la place du marché
de gmac
et puis vous gagnez 2 kg de chocolat et
après votre carrière est lancée ouais
après vous faites les balles les
kermesses les restos enfin une star est
née voilà la région de jeux mac et vous
participez on parlait de l'homme des
voeux bartissol tout à l'heure vous
participez à un radio crochet caravane
rtl monsavon absolue avec une chanson
vous aviez geôliers écrite didier si
j'osais de par les premières chansons
d'amour calmement à une main
ce joli j'avais confié mère de
l'adolescent
non mais bon les fouilles n'était pas
descendre comme elle si le problème
imprévu c'est vrai la raison après
autant de voix est devenue plus rock
oui votre père vous avez voulu vous avez
qui l'aimé pas voter surtout le curé de
la paroisse qui vont envoyer de l'accord
ferrer non mais c'est vrai en fait notre
père était pas content que votre voix
émue et un moment et grâce à ce niveau
j'ai pu continuer parce que les serpents
qui nous a ouvert la voie sans mauvais
jeu de mots ouais vous souvenez cette
nuit blanche vous avez passé la gare du
nord ce dimanche et un chèque de 5000
francs remis par aznavour d'ailleurs et
les banques étaient fermées c'est le
week-end et vous ai passé toute l'année
que votre père salle datant de la gare
du nord oui foot bonheur même temps à
l'époque on ne savait même pas qu'il y
avait des hôtels ça faisait partie d'un
autre
c'était normal qu'on dorme la salle
d'attenté
on l'a beaucoup d' essai discographique
à partir de là ça a mis du temps avant
d'y arriver un beau coup de beaucoup
beaucoup d'échecs aidé par le disquaire
de jemappes monsieur donfut jusqu'au
jour où on va
tu ne viendra pas ce soir
tombe la neige
et mon coeur s'habille de noir
on
avec son coeur dieu
mon coeur messieurs
mua
swann et messieurs à votre bon coeur
messieurs
ou permettez monsieur que j'en pense de
votre site
et puis bien qu'ils me sourit je sens
bien qu'il se dise il y était chouette
les filles du bord de mer
j'ai été fait se posent ils savaient
qu'ils fassent
elle est
le
c'est le curé
il aura tenu sa dernière chanson
et nous à la
je
nous sommes
voilà énorme moi j'étais j'étais déjà là
ils ont d'ailleurs à l'époque 1965 vous
êtes en tête de tous de tous les hit
parades
j'ai pas jouer les rabat joie donc avec
mon premier cachet vous achetez une
maison à vos parents et vous vous
achetez une alfa romeo blanche
sympa justin star énorme
à 22 ans il est déjà vendu six millions
de disques dans le monde et quand vous
faisiez détournés s'étaient vous
remplissiez plus les salles que montand
piaf ou johnny est né jésus bouclé en 66
66 3 deuxième vente de disques que
derrière les beatles virage aux aléas
des road voulait rencontrer paul
mccartney vous allez à des rhodes et en
arrivant vous en paierez la marseillaise
vite c'est pour moi c'est pas tout à
fait comme ça et charles et maroni qui
m'a dit tiens si tu veux venir dire
bonjour aux beatles et parlait de george
martin c'est maintenant et au moment où
j'entre dans leur studio
j'entends la marseillaise charlet c'est
charlie cuisine de vie sont gentils ils
croient que français il te joue la
marseillaise et pendant six mois je les
crues et c'était là trop de all you need
is absolument car les naïfs peut pas
changer tout changer oui je savais pas
que tu es naïf comme ça mais bien et
puis après alors il ya pas mal de pas
mal de galères de nouveau un vous
pulvérisez d'alfa romeo dans un accident
votre père non mais c'est vrai votre
père décède dans la maison vous avez
acheté à côté de raconteur sur une
chemise dallage en sicile en sicile à
côté de la gauche mais ça fait beaucoup
et vous l'aimiez beaucoup parce que
quand vous votre premier vendu 37 et
votre père vous a quand même encouragé
37,10 pas dire c'est pas beaucoup
demande de la famille ah ouais et vous
dit s'il n'avait pas poussé à continuer
à cette époque là j'aurais abandonné
quoi oui moi je
après avoir gagné le crochet le concours
de chant question bombe à la petite
notoriété que j'avais acquis s'est
estompé en quelques mois
et puis j'ai fait un disque de disques 3
10 k 10 qui ne fonctionnait pas et moi
je voulais retourner aux études et c'est
là que mon père m'a vraiment surpris
puisque c'est lui qui m'a dit non
maintenant je sais quelle est ta voix et
il est allé frapper aux portes jusqu'à
ce qu'ils trouvent la bonne alors après
donc j'ai eu une petite traversée du
désert aussi il faut bien le dire un peu
le creux de la vague
c'est dû à quoi votre avis mais est-ce
que c'est dû aux chansons à la qualité
des mélodies tout simplement sans doute
il ya eu entre les deux il ya eu mai 68
le 10 rebonds l'optique d'un certain
public avait bien changé et ils ont
petit considéré comme moi je n'étais pas
capable d'évoluer dans le même sens qu
or si vous voulez je l'avais sait mais
ils ont peut-être pas pris la peine où
les médias n'ont pas pris la peine de
jouer les chansons plus adéquate à
l'époque il s'en tenait à mon image et
sur chaque disque que je sortais alors
que j'essayais de surprendre on aller
repêcher celle qui correspondait le plus
à mon image
donc petit à petit et puis a eu d'autres
chanteurs qui sont venus les gens se
sont tournés vers l'aude ce qui est
normal et moi d'un autre côté je l'avais
l'occasion chanter ailleurs donc je n'ai
pas perçu le danger je me suis peut-être
un peu trop éloigné un moment donné la
seule chose qui vous regretter un peu
c'est peut-être de ne pas vous être bien
occuper de vos enfants non c'est une des
choses en effet que je regrette c'est
que sans doute à certains moments mes
enfants ou du avoir besoin de moi et moi
j'étais pas là et quand je rentrais avec
des cadeaux et je me voyais pas les
enguirlandé donc lâchement j'ai délégué
sur les épaules de ma femme l'a très
bien fait ça abusé un petit peu de votre
statut de papa héros et wissant est
maintenant mes enfants sont grands jeux
on a eu des discussions donc je pense
qu'ils sont convaincus que ça ne pouvait
pas être autrement que leur père est
incertain bancaire
pas le changer excusez moi je perds deux
mois la troisième personne c'était juste
une parenthèse qui souvent